nos produits tours enjaux sont-ils
consommés par les Irlandais
Florent Clavel a mené l'enquête à Dublin
à l'occasion de notre série spéciale
Irlande en vue de la Coupe du monde de
rugby là-bas les boutiques et
restaurants vendent du
Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine ou encore du
Vouvray un marché prometteur pour nos
producteurs locaux regardez
[Musique]
notre quête de produits tours en jeu
nous mène d'abord dans une fromagerie
Cherry down cheese mongers a Dublin 30
ans de métiers et une vingtaine de
boutiques à travers l'Irlande alors
quand on demande
du Sainte-Maure-de-Touraine celui-là a
parcouru 1000 km depuis un producteur
près de celles-sur-cher et il est
aujourd'hui l'un des plus populaires de
la boutique
on en va environ 12 chaque semaine
minimum donc il y a un énorme
renouvellement
de Touraine à de nombreux restaurants
notamment guilbo et chapter one qui sont
deux restaurants étoilettes
comptez 12 euros tout de même pour
retrouver le goût de la Touraine soit le
double de chez nous pour accompagner
notre fromage rien de tel qu'un bon
Vouvray direction cette fois le Luna un
restaurant gastronomique de la ville une
boisson sur deux services et du vin on y
retrouve Suzanne la chef de bar qui nous
dégote un Vouvray sec et encore le
succès est au rendez-vous
oui
on va environ 12 bouteilles chaque
semaine ce qui est plutôt bon sachant
qu'on le vend depuis seulement un mois
ça fait l'un de nos vins les plus
demandés les gens connaissent le
Bouveret c'est assez réputé
mais pas donné vendu un peu plus de 6
euros sur le site du producteur la même
bouteille de Vouvray proposée à 52 euros
au Luna
huit fois plus cher retour en France à
Vouvray justement sur les traces de
notre bouteille curieux de savoir ce qui
a poussé ce vigneron a exporter en
Irlande par l'intermédiaire d'un
grossiste en vin pour Didier Aubert
c'est un marché récent mais prometteur
ça représente à peu près 800 bouteilles
pour en ce moment c'est un beau
démarrage et on demande simplement être
connu parce que pour l'instant on
faisait très peu d'export sur le domaine
et donc
ça ne se fait pas un jour c'est au fil
du temps et de l'eau que ça prospère si
nos vins et nos fromages ravissent le
palais des Irlandais il ne représente
cependant qu'une petite partie du
commerce avec nos voisins la chimie et
la pharmacie arrivent en tête c'est même
40% des exportations totales du
département